so my name is davey i'm a software
engineer and
i love javascript
you love javascript too right
if you love javascript you do this
now look around you if you hate
javascript you do this
now you can squeeze a little bit the
room for the people just press them in
the middle um
and uh okay so
um
i have a bold title so it was a title to
get you in the room so it's i'm happy
that you're all here
write safer javascript what does that
mean safer all right so i'm just quickly
gonna go through
the agenda
we're just going to see javascript
versus typescript getting to love
typescript and migrating from javascript
to typescript but i need to answer this
question first what safer means
no bugs oh i like that it's very
ambitious man
i like that
let's say again
easier debugging how many people here in
the room do javascript really
very good now keep your hands up
how about typescript
okay so i don't have to convince you
really i'm just gonna make sure that the
end of the session when i say tab script
everyone let raise their hands and they
want to do that every day
so yeah that's that's that's
that's the problem
you know that right
cannot read property bar often define
or
null is not an object
or you're trying to call a function
cannot reproperty value often defined
that's really common
foo is not a function
um
cannot reproperty length of undefined
that's where i that's that's the safer
part i'm talking about right i'm not
talking about security and all this
stuff i'm just talking about the fact
that you can you can write code that
doesn't crash
um
in production so that's a runtimes error
right so we have two things run times
errors
and
compile time errors right so while
you're writing your code you you'll be
able to see this with typescript we'll
be able to detect that up front okay
so
javascript vs typescript
javascript is yellow
you know that color right
that's javascript
typescript is blue
javascript
is
whoever is doing javascript only in the
room is already doing typescript
okay
because typescript is a superset of
javascript the way i introduce
typescript to teams
that we coach
i told i tell them typescript is a
documentation tool
i'm gonna show you why i'm i'm calling
it the documentation tool yeah it looks
like a programming language
but as you start using it you're gonna
realize that it is more
documentation tools than the programming
language so that yellow thing you or
all all of you are doing it and the blue
part
is what typescript brings on top of the
table so yeah touchscript is a super set
of javascript the way it's described on
a microsoft website is javascript dot
scales
okay
so
small demo time
just gonna take the
a thing called typescript playgrounds
okay so you can follow up with you can
follow with me on this one if you want
so um it's a small um
can you see this let me put it full
screen
so let me remove this
so
keep in mind that what i'm about to show
you is the fact that
javascript
touchscript is a superset of javascript
okay
so in javascript we have class
let's say user
as you can see on the left on the left
here is typescript on the right is
javascript
the only difference between the two is
just the used trick
so far
so we're still in the the yellow zone
everyone yeah you write typescript
you're doing you're basically having
one-on-one javascript on the other side
okay that's the yellow zone
and then um you want to write to
let's say
a variable cost
user
we're still in the yellow zone right
so far so good
so then
you will say what is user
in typescript you can express
documentation
you can express
that user
is a user
he's of class type user guess what i'm
using type right i'm using this to to
document that line i'm using that class
i'm using a class
but i'm gonna show you in a few seconds
that you shouldn't be doing it you
shouldn't do that
but
stay with me for a second
i'm still having a kind of 101 but i
don't have this anymore i don't see this
thing here
that that typing documentation i'm just
documenting my code but look what's
going to happen
here now i'm going to say um
user has
login which is a string
[Music]
by hiding login here right away here
this is this is this isn't working
anymore
on the other side we still have the same
translation but this this isn't working
that won't stop your program to work
but at least you see it right away
that's what we were talking about
compile time
now if i want to fix it i'm just gonna
have to have to add a login here that
says davey
fix it
we're still in the yellow zone
now i'm gonna take you to the blue zone
okay
why aren't you happy
again
yeah it just asked me to give him a
default value that's it that's what he
wants
which is a good thing
now i'm gonna take you to the the blue
zone
instead of using a class i'm just gonna
use an interface and then i don't need
to if it's an interface it's a contract
i don't need to initialize that anymore
but look left and right
on the right i only have the cost
and on the left
i have
i have this interface here on the left
and only the the user translation on the
right
see i use an interface to type my my uh
my object
but i don't overload the final
javascript that is
rendered so the only thing i really did
right here
i documented this
documentation
okay i'm going to show you another
example of documentation that you can do
is to say i want the user to go
toward a certain direction
okay
so
right away
you can see that
it's not happy because you just had a
property like you will do in javascript
and let me just hide that property
quickly oh well
the property you just had has an impact
all the way
in the chain because people are using
or they don't expect that property but
you just had that and then in production
boom
direction
of whatever is undefined
okay
but i want that that direction here to
come from a new
or i can say
enumeration let's say direction
okay
so as you can see here
i had an enumeration
and then right away i have this magic
happening here
this line
that direct and then i will just add
left
and then right
for example
okay
so yeah there is a there is a one-on-one
uh translation from enum to something
that looks like this
if you don't understand that part of the
cut it's okay
is is is just they're using some closure
to create a variable and then they
encapsulate the entire thing and then
that that gives you a way to to assign a
left and right property on an object
dynamically
so now here i can say
this thing
is a direction that let's say left but
i'm still having a problem here so what
i'm gonna do just to add the direction
property
and then say this one is a direction
is of type direction
okay it's just an enum
it's documentation here i'm expressing
the fact that you can go left and right
i could have used an object const
object direction and then left and right
that will have yield the same result
but see how
you can make it
much more appealing here
just gonna say cost
you see what happened there
it's all disappeared there is no more
overload of
javascript that you're gonna you're
gonna give to your customer because
that's the part your customer will use
in their app in the final app they run
but you
in your code you express
something to make the work of your team
easier
that's that's that's the message i want
to pass here the fact that
typescript is documentation
we good so far
so
let me quickly go back here
so getting to love typescript
and
[Music]
i'm gonna take
something quickly here for you
so i have this function set value
when i say um set value i'm going to
receive this value and i say if value
var real value and then value here so if
i call it
can you can you all see this
good
if i call set value
and i do this
and then i say um
set the value um
to be
yeah here i actually need to say this
and then this that would probably be
much realistic and then here i say
davey
and then here i say
and number
12.
guess what is happening here
what do you think is going to be yield
here on line 9
there is so yeah
it that doesn't work that won't work
yeah
so see now we're already talking about
the fact that hosting is gonna be in
into play here it's gonna enter into
play here
right so there is already kind of
understanding javascript but as well
understanding the fact that are we going
to enter here
is this code is is written in a sense
like
this can enter here
first line nine
is it going to enter here
no
and then the two two other cases we
enter but
regardless we're gonna have undefined
here
and then
dv and then 12
okay
but that
i'm gonna have to open the code source
and then start making sense of what
you're trying to do
i can make it much easier by saying
value
could be
either a string
or
a number
see
by doing those these two already are
solved but how about this part
i can communicate via documentation
that this part is sometime
optional
i'm just documenting my code
that's all i'm doing
okay
so
once you you reach that part
there's some magic that's gonna happen
here and then yeah you can use a good
let here that will make your life much
easier but if you do so you see the
scope gonna enter and play and that's
not typescript that is just raw
javascript
so
let me just move it here then it doesn't
crash
and then i can i can
set the value right here
okay
now it's not over because i still need
to do something that looks like what is
the possible return value because if you
give me a string or number
i can also have as return value a string
and a number
i'm just
expressing what my code is supposed to
do
but here is the thing the day the day i
discover what i'm about to show you
i discovered that in touchscript and i
was like there is no way i'm doing
javascript again
i'm gonna show you that line of code
i was here and i said value dot
because i already said string or number
when i say value dot i only get
to string or value
right
but then one step further
i realized that if i have an if
condition like this one
and i can say
type of
value
is equal
let's say
string
now inside here when i say value
dot
that at this moment my brain just did
there is no way you're not doing
typescript in your life
just that
because just with that all the screen
has shown you
function doesn't exist and what have
disappeared entirely
yeah some some cases won't work entirely
but this gives you
what i'm trying to show you okay
so i can go much further i'm happy to
talk about it right after so
what i'm saying here typescript is a
documentation tool
it is a documentation tool
so the next question will be
if you had
if you have a huge javascript project
how can you go from javascript to
typescript
there are three steps
three
the first one is super easy
just make it work
you know what i mean here
you take
you generate a ts config file
ts config
which is a typescript configuration
and then you add
set implicit any which is just a
property in your ts config you just put
it at false
what does that mean it means any
javascript it just make sure that you're
still in the
yellow zone
right that's it that's all it does it
doesn't yell at you but typescript is
already there
so you're still in your
javascript project not typescript
touchscript is just behind watching
everything at first then
you rename all your js file to
ts or tsx if you're using a react and
then pre-act and all these two
that's it
don't don't don't force that on to your
team just just do this
they won't they won't see it
yeah
they will see the ts thing right but for
them that won't really change in terms
of the code they write every day
right that's one step
second one
now be explicit
don't ch turn the any
to instead instead of first put it that
true you know what's going to happen
it will just put some
red line between the things that are
that don't have types
that's it that's all it's going to do
everything is still okay
all right
you can put that on your teammates
they'll be okay they will just be like
we we have new red flags what is
happening here
then you tell them
let's just
take all the the types the command types
like if you're on a node project just do
a npm install at type node
just do that
this is a common type it's they're all
known once they're in your project most
of the red thing will will just vanish
because it will recognize that no typing
or it's it's there that's it
well don't do that in two days just you
do the first step then you wait three
months then you do this part okay
and then
you add typing for third-party
tools
like a library you're using and stuff
like that you have typing for that
okay
now that part you should leave that for
a few months i'm not kidding because the
third part is where you get you get into
war
the third part is be straight
means that
you just go in the the
typescript config file and then you put
strict
to true
so what does that mean it means that
your project isn't working anymore
it just means that now we're gonna have
to type everything you're gonna have to
express every single line of code
in your application
that's what it means
okay i want i i have i have a repo for
you i have a repo for you where i have
those three steps it's in the the
resource part
and um you can just check the three
steps okay
with that
i hope that
um
you'll be able to play with touchscript
a little bit more i'm gonna be outside
answering questions if you want to to
drink typescript i'll be here if you
want to
think typescript with react i'm gonna
help touchscript with vue.js i'm gonna
help
i know those things typescript with
angular i'm not i'm not gonna help
because it's already there so just go
and do it
and
voila questions
[Applause]